Deals with alcoholism and
at the biological level,
that's what I did my phd thesis on and
much of my early published papers where I
learned about brain function because
alcohol affects every part of the brain.
So I learned a lot about the brain.
What prompted my interest in that area.
And you're a parent shift,
two issues clustered around personality.
While I was always interested in
motivation for drug and alcohol abuse,
you know what it was the
drove people to use drugs of,
of,
of abuse,
let's say.
And um,
I got the opportunity to study
at Miguel under Dr Robert Peel,
who was an excellent supervisor
and he was deeply involved with,
um,
drug and alcohol abuse research,
looking at motivation for alcoholism.
And he offered me a
position in his lab and,
and that was what he was working on.
And I thought,
well,
that was one of my cardinal interests,
although perhaps not my,
my fundamental interest,
which even at that point had to do with
motivation for totalitarianism and the
Commission of atrocity in the service of,
of group belief.
But I thought,
well,
it's a broad topic and I could learn a
lot about biology and neurobiology as a
consequence of working on
something that was so biological.
So my,
my early work in psychology was extremely
biologically oriented and it was
unbelievably useful.
I learned a lot from the animal
experimentalists in particular people like
Jeffrey Gray and later Jaak Panksepp.
Um,
I have a reading list at Jordan B.
Peterson Dotcom that outlines
some of those emotional,
so those books on emotional neuroscience.
Um,
what was my,
why did I shift?
Well there was a variety of reasons.
One was that the National Institute of
Alcohol Abuse and alcoholism and I AAA,
which funded grant research in the United
States essentially made the corn of
research I was doing with Robert Peale.
Impossible.
And it's part of the consequence.
I think this is one of the things that
the universities are doing so terribly
wrong,
is the ethics committees made our
research impossible both to fund and to
implement.
So here's why.
So we were bringing people into the lab.
So here's who we pick for subjects.
If you are going to be a subject
in one of our experiments,
you had to be a young man and you had
to have an alcoholic father and an
alcoholic grandfather and at least
one other first or second degree male
alcoholic relative.
Well,
I hope I'm back again.
You know,
my software updated and
obviously the update has a bug,
so that's rather annoying.
Um,
apologies for that.
Once again.
So back to the alcoholism discussion.
Um,
where was I?
Oh yes.
So we would get these subjects.
I,
I mentioned who they were,
they were young men who weren't alcoholic,
but who drank socially,
who had an alcoholic father,
an alcoholic grandfather,
and at least one other
male alcoholic relative.
Now why did we pick subjects like that?
Well,
we knew alcoholism ran in families and
we couldn't really study its transmission
and women because if you're a female
alcoholic and you drink when you have a
child in Utero,
then the child can have fetal alcohol
syndrome and whatever abnormalities in
psychophysiological response
or psychopathologies
might be associated with,
uh,
their alcoholism can easily be masked by
the presence of fetal alcohol syndrome.
So we couldn't use women and besides
alcoholism is a problem that fundamentally
characterized as men.
Although there are female alcoholics,
I think it's four to one if I remember
correctly from from those days,
it's four to one male to female,
so it was,
we know when we thought if we
concentrated on those who had the highest
probability of developing
alcoholism because of their
loaded family history that
we could shed some light on the mechanisms
associated with alcoholism and that
would be useful for men and for women.
So we studied sons of male alcoholics,
sons of multigenerational male alcoholics.
Those were our target group,
very hard populations to find.
We have people hired full time to do
nothing but find us research subjects and
so we did relatively small end studies
because we were lucky if we could gather
four or five subjects a month
in the Montreal urban area.
Anyways,
we did discover a lot about alcoholism.
We discovered for example,
that if people with this
multigenerational history,
a substantial proportion of them,
if they drank enough alcohol to move
their blood level up above 0.08 which is
legal intoxication level.
And if they did that relatively
short period of time,
then their heart rate
would increase above,
I think the average was about 12 beats
per minute compared to the standard
control of,
of zero zero or one or two.
It was is very low.
And so,
and then we did figure out over time
our whole team that that seemed to be a
consequence of susceptibility to alcohol's
effect on opioid production in the
brain.
And Secondary,
uh,
opioid effects on dopamine,
which is both opiates and dopamine
are primarily primary reward chemical.
So it looked to us like people with
multigenerational family histories of
alcoholism got an opiate
response from alcohol.
So,
but we had to get people drunk
in order to find this response.
And it turned out that 0.08,
which was the legal limit at that time
for driving was approximately the place
where we saw the psychophysiological
effects and also saw fairly pronounced
cognitive and motor effects of
alcohol because we also studied that.
So now to bring,
we bring people into the lab and we'd
give them three large shots of alcohol
that they consumed in 10 minutes.
We use laboratory alcohol,
which was I think 95% pure alcohol,
usually put it in orange juice.
Um,
and so people would be,
you know,
reasonably intoxicated.
And then we would let them sober
up until they were at 0.04,
which is half legal intoxication,
which we thought was useful.
And then we put them in a cabin
and they'd go home and we,
you know,
we had our odd mishap now and then
someone would throw up and that was,
well I'm at least getting better
at fixing it when it screws up now.
So um,
you know when it anyways,
now and then we would have somebody who
would be becoming all in the lab and
that was always unpleasant.
But then we also let people sober up and
it actually takes quite a long time to
go from point a to 0.04,
especially if you're a big guy cause your,
your dose of alcohol is
proportionate to your body weight.
And so we used to have people wait
in the lab for a couple of hours.
So you know,
and they were not very happy necessarily
about having to wait before we paid
them and so forth.
And,
and if we didn't treat
them extraordinarily well,
which we tried to do,
then of course they were much less
likely to come back and participate in
another study.
And since it was very difficult
to get research subjects,
then we wanted to treat them very well
apart from the fact that we would have
done that anyways.
But then,
and I AAA said,
well,
you can't let your research subjects
go home until they have a blood alcohol
level of point.
Oh two was like,
we would have had to
have people in our lab,
you know,
sobering up for
okay.
For six to eight hours.
This keeps happening.
I'm very sorry about this,
everyone.
Okay.
I don't know what to say about it except
that that's a consequence of software
updates I suppose.
Um,
anyways,
so that made it impossible because we
just couldn't keep people in the lab for
that long.
All it did was annoyed them to death
and then they hated us and they,
you know,
people would get quite irritable
and upset and no bloody wonder.
So then also,
and I AAA decided that half our subjects
had to be women or we couldn't get
funding.
Well,
no,
our subjects couldn't be women.
It was impossible to do the kind of
research that we were doing with women for
the reasons that I just don't like.
Well,
first of all,
um,
alcoholism doesn't affect women
as much as it affects men.
Depression and anxiety tend to affect
women more than it's perfectly reasonable
to study those things.
But that isn't what we were doing.
And,
uh,
and then we couldn't do
multigenerational studies for,
for genetic predisposition with women
because of the fetal alcohol syndrome
problem.
And you know,
this was something,
I think this came in under the Clintons,
this re requirement for
absolute gender equality in,
in subject selection.
And they didn't give a damn if that
meant that there were certain kinds of
research that just
couldn't be done anymore.
And so I had to stop doing it.
And no one's really doing that kind of
research anymore because it's just too
difficult.
It's like it was always a pain because
it was really hard to get the subjects
and then you had to get people quite
intoxicated and then you had to deal with
them when they were drunk and you had
to do your psychophysiological recording
and all that of thing.
And then they had to
sober up and you know,
it was complicated.
Clinical research is unbelievably,
unbelievably complicated and difficult.
And then yeah,
I would like to more restrictions
to it and people just go,
oh,
okay,
well we,
I guess we won't study
the psychophysiological
consequences of alcohol anymore
or so people would use low doses,
you know,
and only get their subject's blood
alcohol level up to like 0.02 or 0.03 but
that's completely irrelevant because
alcohol doesn't have much of a
physiological effect.
It,
those low doses.
And so while this is one of the things
that made me absolutely despise ethics
committees,
and I believe that the proliferation of
ethics committees is one of the reasons
that university research
human research is,
is,
is doing badly.
Psychological research is doing badly.
There's a variety of reasons,
but that's certainly one of them.
So I was interested,
sorry this is a very long answer,
but I was interested
in personality as well.
You know,
because I was a clinical psychologist
and I'd read Freud and Jung and Adler and
all the great clinicians
of the 20th century.
And when I went to Harvard I was offered,
you know,
I,
when you're a new faculty member,
there's usually a set course
that they require you to teach.
That's one of the core courses.
And then you have some freedom
with your other courses.
And so I said I'd teach personality and
then I got more and more and we were
looking at personality models
with the alcoholism research too.
At that point,
the big five was starting
to establish itself.
And I wasn't much of an admirer
of the big five because I like,
while I like theories as
well as empirical research.
And I thought the big five,
while there was just no theory at all,
it was just brute force empiricism,
but well,
but you know,
that data eventually became convincing.
And as I got more and more interested in,
um,
in personality,
I got more and more interested in the
use of personality and other psychometric
technologies to predict things
like academic and creative success.
You see it at McGill,
my Bob and I and a variety
of other people were using,
um,
psychological tests of various sorts
to predict things like alcoholism and
antisocial personality.
So we could use the big five
and neuropsychological tests,
tests of Dorsolateral prefrontal function,
at least in principle,
to predict to some degree who might
be susceptible to the development of
antisocial personality.
And then when I went to Harvard,
I thought,
well,
hey,
maybe we could use those tests to predict
who was going to be good at things as
well as who was going to be bad.
You know,
the people who are creative
are the people who were,
um,
academically,
outstanding or people who did well
as managers and administrators and
corporations might do well
on personality tests and,
and neuropsychological tests that assess
dorsolateral prefrontal functions.
That's higher order cognition.
So we started to put together test
batteries that assessed that and that was
fascinating research.
I did that with Daniel Higgins,
who's the partner,
my partner in the development of the
self authoring program and understand
myself that things that he's labored
for years on before they really became
successful.
Um,
and he wrote a bang up thesis.
I think it was the best
thing ever written on this,
on the topic of intelligence.
And,
and launched that he
started working on in,
in 1993,
which is about the same time
that the bell curve came out.
And so his research actually became
row relatively politically contentious,
even though all we were trying to do
was trying to determine what attributes
predicted success among creative people
and among managers and administrators
and,
and academia and so forth,
pure empirical research.
But it became real,
very rapidly politicized anyways.
So I just got more and more
interested in psychometrics,
partly because I realized way back
when in 1993 that almost nothing that's
psychologists measured was actually real.
And so we were interested
in what was real.
And Daniel is an engineer trained at Mit.
And so he was very,
very method method,
a methodical person.
And he didn't like to move
ahead with his research at all,
unless he had nailed absolutely everything
down in a way that only an engineer
and a software coder would.
And so we started working on personality
models and I've been doing that and
concentrating on that more
specifically ever since,
as well as writing the more theoretical
material that was associated,
say with 12 rules for
life in maps of meaning.